i don't know same okay good sir knight i
love carlo a great man to explain
complex ideas simply to a person like
myself he said before that he took
psychedelics when he was young i think
it was lsd
and it was a satori moment which helped
him think about time and physics in
novel ways has he done psychedelics
since and if so has it given him any new
insights or confirmed his theories in
any way
um this psychedelic said my youth a few
times
you know 10 times maybe uh no more
uh 15 maybe um
and then i have not
done it since uh
and i don't know maybe i i will in the
future
nowadays things
so what the world think about
psychedelics is changing it's changing
very rapidly
so
things might become simpler
now
um
it was important for me
it was a
very strong
experience like
many people who
had it say
um
uh
do you recall your dosage
um
no
but comparing to descriptions uh which
you find the literature was certainly
quite high oh yeah
wow yeah
yeah
definitely high um
i mean
compared to the strongest
accounts of of of
similar experience that you find
nowadays easily
in in all sorts of literature
um
you know
steve jobs the the head
of apple said that take lsd this youth
was one of the two most important strong
experience of his life i i think i could
subscribe that it was very strong buddy
um it definitely did not i did not
get direct physical ideas by taking nst
so i don't uh suggest you know take lsd
so you write good paper in physics
that's not the way it works
um i was young and it was many many
years from there to the actual physics
i did however
i believe it's true that
it did affect
my way of thinking about reality
especially um in a sort of
liberatory sense i mean sort of how i
came out i was young again
i guess the first time i was 16.
i came out with from that experience
saying thinking wait a minute what we
usually think about space and time and
matter and energy and mind and me and
the world and that uh
that's just one way of thinking about
things maybe there are all sorts of
other ways of thinking about that and my
brain is can can view things
very very differently for a while so it
might be possible to think differently
so
i came out from that experience maybe it
was also the culture at the time um
with an extremely
large a purely flexibility
about
possibilities right right i can imagine
that
in terms of you know political ideas
moral ideas social ideas
but also physical idea i mean i
i had a distinctive sense that this
organization in space and in time that
we
usually perceive about the world could
just change with a little chemical
so we are clinical so
you know why should one be better than
the other
and this stayed with me
and i think that one
first
it gave me curiosity
because when i later on 10 years later
i studied physics
and read that you know einstein
discovered that simultaneity is not
well defined
i said well about it this
i you know i do i knew that things were
more complicated than what they looked
at the first side
um and then when i studied generativity
quantum mechanics i was ready to accept
very easily the idea
that the world could perhaps be
profoundly different that i would
imagine of it didn't scare me the idea
because somehow it's that idea that i
had confronted so in that sense i think
it was very useful um
for this no more than that
did you get to a state of a temporality
where you didn't feel like there was
time passing yeah or eternity like
infinite time passage yeah that's one of
the uh
i say more common
um
things that people say
namely that
time it's uh
the sense of time is completely
destroyed in in many ways i mean i would
say the simplest way
which i remember very well
very beginning is just you know having
the sense of watching the looking at the
at the watch
and then you know hours and hours later
watching it again and uh realizing that
the minute had passed so wait a minute i
mean all this happened in one minute i
mean my god which is one of the things
people get scared
right so one of the things i mean the
only problem with lsd if you get scared
and you
you get terrorized and it can be
extremely psychologically dangerous yeah
it can be very bad it doesn't happen
often but it's uh
i think it's the only real problem in
these things the only real danger of
this is having a
couple a few very bad hours which may
look very wrong and then one of the
reasons you get scared is when you
realize that you know you feel the time
is passing but it's not passing outside
you you feel trapped
oh my god i'm here and then come out of
you okay because here for me time is
it's it's passing and outside it's not
passing so that's one of the security
but that's
extraordinary strong distortion of the
sense of how much time is fast it's just
one aspect of it because
i think the sense that people talk about
that it's a sense of completely destroy
what it means by temporal organization
of the world
and the other common thing is this
distinction between yourself and the
outside right it's a basic
it's a basic
uh category in our think about valid you
know there's me in the rest me it's me
and the rest is rest
and this is something which
was very clear in my experiences is
common in many reports of this
experience is that you use
the sense of you as a self separate
distinct from
from the rest it's very strong it's very
physical the lsd experience is a very
uh it's it's a very
uh powerful thing in fact i remember
spending days and days after that
sort of under the shock was not bad but
it was also
disturbing tiring
i mean my mind had kept going back to
that for what has happened it means oh
my god what has happened where am i who
am i what is
um
not unpleasant for me it was never been
unpleasant it has always been pleasant
very pleasant extremely pleasant i had
i i faced it without preparation
but my friend was with me who had no
preparation and no
experience either
actually said the right thing at the
very beginning and was near to me
um
the right thing being don't be scared
whatever happens don't worry just let it
go and uh just don't resist and just be
aware that then you come back and
whatever happens you you back yourself
so
um
that's really a sure because he said
exactly right i think the moment in
which i got scared i remembered that and
say okay i'll trust him let things go
and let this strange experience go go
over you
um
i loved it it stayed with me and somehow
in the moment in which am in deep [ __ ]
which we all go through in our life
i remember that moment there is it's
it's calming to me it says good
i look at my hands the way i looked at
my hands in that and i
i have a sense of
separation from reality and uh
and the beauty of reality they started
beauty of reality in front of me just
how it is
um
which i
remember as a gift of that particular
moment that stays with me all my life
was it a moment of utter peace or
euphoria
like what was what would be the word
that you would characterize it
these people would say positive but
there's so many different senses of the
word positive
right
no we're not called peace we're not
called serene
i was not called euphoria
either um i don't know emotionally
it was a
completely overwhelming
uh
surprise
uh
and a sense of
violent
almost joy at some moment
oh wow i feel overwhelmed by the beauty
of things
i like seeing things for the first time
this is
strange thing like like if i was oh my
god i've never seen that but this is
just you know my hand or a tree believe
anything
um
and by overwhelmed by the beauty of it
and be aware that you know it's just a
leaf and just i could look at it as an
incredibly beautiful thing it's just me
and that's my heart opening up and just
exploding but
it's notoriously hard to describe those
experiences everybody says so and now
there's a growing literature
because
finally scientists can study these
substances after it was forbidden to
study these scientists substances for 40
years it's completely stupid because why
should you know people study poisons or
you know heroin
why shouldn't you study this language
um
so i hope that now the regulatory body
uh
take away this silly
yes yeah yeah
forbidding
studying these things
so it didn't directly help you with
physics but it helped you with
entertaining ideas that other people
would consider unpalatable such as time
doesn't exist or so-and-so is relational
rather than real
exactly
exactly so
in other words
lee small and you need to give lee
smalling some lsd to dissuade him of his
ideas of the prime minister
and that's what i'm going to read
between the lines okay
last two questions last two
go to do you know who
whitehead is alfred north whitehead
yeah okay so this question comes from
aaron haidari says ravelli seems to
reflect
a lot of the pen
theist process philosophy that whitehead
talks about i wonder if he's familiar
with whitehead and what he
thinks of this more organic view of
reality yeah
well um
i i got to know what had precisely
because uh other people already
pointed out similarities uh um
especially uh thinking
reality as a process
if not that entities
um entities with property but
happening of things so
processes before things
um
definitely there is this resonance and
the similarity and i'm sure that's
you know my way of thinking might have
been affected by by him or by people who
were affected by him
um
so i read i started reading
uh some of his books because of that
because people pointed out this
analogies
and i i saw the analogy so i saw the
similarities i tried to get something
useful from it but there is a size
there is a
an aspect of it
which i don't
connect to um
which is this more organic or even
spiritualist
right there's a somehow
the way he faces the problems i i
couldn't
in spite of definite uh
similarities in this main idea that
we we we described the world as a
process but not
but but i'm a deeply a physicist um
a physicalist
i i think that the
the physical description of the world
that we have now it's it's it's very
good as it is um
it doesn't need to
uh
to be reinforced by
by other pieces it has to be better
understood perhaps
and and i try to read what we know about
the world at that level
um from the physics itself and i think
it's not contradictory with a higher
level description of the world
okay with the ones given by biology by
sociology by psychology by you know
everything i think there's a there's
coherence we don't understand many of
the intermediate steps
uh but there's clearance between these
different pictures of of of the wall
well of course we need the higher level
ones because uh
because we cannot i cannot describe my
girlfriends who are using maxwell
equations that doesn't work there's no
contradiction between she being made by
atoms uh
governed by the maxwell equations
and you know she being somebody i love
and she loves me and we interact on the
level of our
emotions
uh they're just different different
levels of description some which works
better as some aggregate of things and
some which works better
and and
i don't see any a priori contradiction
between that and there's no need
to
to add higher level notions to the
fundamental notions